new mutants are dangerous that's why
you're here Oh scary it's a cage
together we can get out of here
that was so hot what's the last thing
you remember Danny he said we had to run
would anyone like to shared their first
time brain I was 13 I thought it was a
dream I just lost control Sam I started
panicking people got hurt
Roberto my girlfriend
Liliana
I killed 18 men one by
[Music]
this isn't a hospital it's a cage
it's important we find out your collar
so we can help you get better
I suppose something
I don't think she wanted me to see
I don't think we're here to cut better
we can get out of this together
[Music]
welcome back everyone its charlie marble
dropped another New Mutants trailer
because they just announced a new
release date so we'll break it down
there's some Easter eggs and some other
big x-men Marvel news inside the MCU so
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we might
actually have a chance at seeing the new
mutants movie at this point when we get
a little closer to the movie coming out
I will do movie ticket giveaways but as
you see the movie is now coming out
August 28th right after Wonder Woman
1984 look at the story that's told by
all these New Mutants movie posters
these are all the different release
dates on it the first one just says
coming soon because it was the teaser
poster but then you notice that each of
the dates year by year just keep
changing until finally we hit August
28th later this summer that's how many
times they've tried to release this
movie first Fox and then now Marvel the
reason why they're trying for August and
not doing a little bit sooner is just
because August is when most of the major
studios are expecting things to get back
to normal at least enough for most
people to feel safe enough to go to a
movie theater and for most of the major
movie theatres changed to have
completely reopened even if it's a
diminished capacity
even if ticket sales aren't great
because people are still afraid of the
virus and the whole world just isn't
quite ready to go back to movie theaters
in public they still make way more money
by putting it in theaters first before
video on-demand but the big thing that
Disney and all the other movie studios
are doing is it shrinking the window for
when it goes to video on demand so it
used to be about 90 days after a
theatrical release that you could get it
on video on-demand platforms now it's
gonna be like half that so the movie
comes out at the end of August you'll
probably be able to buy it on iTunes and
other video on-demand platforms within
about two months of that and then a
month after that it'll probably hit
Disney Plus so regardless of how you
decide to see New Mutants you'll
probably be watching it before you have
a chance to see the Black Widow movie
which isn't coming out till November now
they recently released some more new
footage separately from this because
even though we didn't know when the
movie was coming out before this they
still wanted to promote it so the
Twitter account has been posting some
new stuff here and there this is just a
much better look at the limbo dimension
that Magik teleports into to fight demon
bear in his physical form he's the main
villain of the New Mutants movie I've
talked about him in a couple of my
trailer videos
for it's all about the very first New
Mutants comic book arc they're adapting
for the movie and while this is
technically Marvel's first big x-men
movie that they're releasing because
they just bought Fox and Fox had already
made the movie for the most part the
actors and the producers have talked
about what's going on behind the scenes
with these characters in the future of
this franchise if New Mutants is
successful the director has talked about
plans for a sequel originally they plan
to do a trilogy when it was still back
at Fox
they were gonna spin up to more Hellfire
Club stuff that we're gonna introduce
mr. sinister through these movies and
eventually they probably would have
crossed over with the more legit
mainstream x-men movies the big change
they made at Marvel Studios now though
is they're kind of treating this like a
one-off just to see how things go right
now Marvel Studios x-men plans are
actually a little bit different because
they have a bunch of different
characters that they want to introduce
you have the stuff that's going on
during Black Panther 2 in the x-men that
they want to introduce during that movie
then you have Ryan Reynolds in the
Deadpool 3 movie over on the other side
that's kind of its own thing to not
necessarily mainstream MCU yet even
though they do want to try and get
Deadpool into an MCU movie I'm hoping
it's released sooner than later but I
know Disney's super excited about it
they've bought it from Fox where I used
to I used to work and Deadpool yeah what
was Fox and then now it is in the hands
of Marvel over there is knee yeah and
what and and and Kin Kin Kin those
worlds be combined we don't know I don't
I see so much
I see infinite possibility in either
version you know if Dad were to be in
the Marvel comic universe I think or the
Marvel Cinematic Universe rather I think
it would be explosive and amazing and
what a sandbox to play in
if Deadpool continued to get to just do
his own thing and be his own thing also
just like infinite possibility then you
have the full-blown Marvel x-men reboot
movies with different actors playing the
characters that's a little further off
what you'll start seeing though is
little characters pop up here and there
I know a lot of people are wondering -
what about x-23 because even though Hugh
Jackman said that he's never coming back
as Wolverine you still have the actress
who plays Laura who's still pretty young
she's a teenager now so she looks quite
a bit
older than she did in that movie but she
could still play a version of x-23 in
the MCU the problem was stuff like that
is that you have to explain Wolverine
before you can explain x-23 and it's
gonna be a couple years before we find
out who the new version of Wolverine is
going to be in the MCU
even though Mark Ruffalo has been going
on and on about pitching a hulk
wolverine crossover movie i've already
done a couple videos about the future of
the hulk character inside the MCU Mark
Ruffalo is sticking around and he's
pitching projects to Kevin Feige
including a Disney Plus series that's
like a revival of The Incredible Hulk
TV series as well as movies stuff the
reason why Wolverine has so much history
with the Hulk character is because of
all the Easter eggs through the weapons
Plus program and Thunderbolt Ross
they're sort of getting into that during
the Falcon and Winter Soldier series
later this year and if you're all bummed
out because of the virus and you're
looking for some good news
the Disney CEO that just took over
actually said that none of the Disney
Plus series are going to be delayed this
year and while New Mutants is gonna be
the first mutant based movie that Marvel
releases one division is really where
we're gonna start seeing mutants in the
MCU legit mutants even though
technically Scarlet Witch is already a
mutant in the MCU it's just that before
the Fox Disney buyout there to be really
careful about the way they use that term
because part of the deal the gave Fox
control of all the x-men also gave them
exclusive rights to use the term mutants
in movies which is why up to this point
you've never heard anybody inside an MCU
movie say the word mutant but obviously
the big thing now Marvel phase 4 is
that's all going to change because it's
not a consideration they have the rights
to all those characters back they can
say mutant as many times as they want in
another Marvel x-men related news there
were recent rumors that they were
planning a revival of x-men the animated
series for Disney Plus the same way that
they revived Young Justice for the DC
streaming service most of you are
probably at least a little familiar with
x-men the animated series wherever you
encountered it but what happened is is
originally it was cancelled because of a
dispute with the network not because it
was unpopular hopefully they find a way
to bring it back or even just do another
partial season a while ago the creators
even said that they had pitched Marvel
Studios on doing an official revival
Kevin Feige himself said he was a big
fan of the series inside note around
that same time you were also probably
spider-man the animated series the 1990s
version that was cancelled at the same
time as x-men the animated series by Fox
for the same reason just another dispute
with the network so they canceled all
the animated series that they were doing
at the time and if that wasn't getting
you hyped enough Marvel was also
recently doing a bunch with the animated
episodes they did a big rewatch project
a little while ago talking to the
original creators of x-men the animated
series so it just sounds like it's all
part of Marvel's grand plan to try and
hype up more x-men animated projects in
the future as well I know how you feel
about it everyone let me know in the
comments though if New Mutants actually
does do well surprisingly at the box
office or financially and they want to
keep the characters around what do you
want them to do with future New Mutants
movies do you want them to do a sequel
as a Disney Plus series do you want it
to be its own thing do you want them to
crossover with other big Marvel
characters post all your predictions in
the comments below and we'll cross our
fingers that nothing else changes they
don't bump the release schedule again
while you wait for everything click here
for my brand-new Deadpool 3 video and
click here for my brand new Mandalorian
a season 2 video thank you so much for
watching everyone stays safe I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]